now the actual dimensions of a name for
piece of paper 29 x 7 x 21 legit that's
which isn't it right that's that's
pretty terrible okay so what I'm going
to do is assume an April paper is an
april piece of paper is 30 x 20 now as
you will discover shortly that doesn't
actually make it so much better anyway
but it will make it slightly quicker for
the algebra okay yeah what's better okay
so our question is remember the idea is
that you are cut out corners okay that
are squares and then we're going to fold
it up and make a box okay so my question
is what are they what's the dimensions
and volume of the biggest box previous
five others biggest my volume okay now
again this is a great example the fact
that it's a simple setup right there's
very little so we need to actually
prepare to paper and try and add in some
complexities so we can actually start to
solve it okay so the first thing you
should do is for yourself an April piece
of paper okay now remember the idea is
that squares get cut out of the corners
all right so you're going to get this
kind of situation now think back to the
previous question you're the idea is
that you've got some quantity that you
want to last time was minimizing just
time I want to maximize right what's the
quantity so I want some expression for
volume right I also want it in terms of
one variable okay hey look at this
there's actually a variety of different
things that you could choose as your
variable okay so for instance you could
choose this lengthier okay you call that
X right now if this is 20 by 30 okay
that would make the dimensions of the
squares let's see you run X here that's
20 across so the twenty-
and there's two of them right now
because that's a square there you've got
another one there so this would be or
that be 30 minus 20 minus x 30 minus 20
minus X right so will that be 10 plus X
yeah of course because that's 30 that's
me right so you can do it like this and
your volume of this box that you get
when you fold it up would be let's think
mm x I 10 plus X 5 20 minus X on who
okay so then you differentiate that okay
now this will give us the answer just
fine um I'm not actually sure if this is
the simplest way to do it I'll show you
the way that I did it in my head I
instead of calling that next you can
pick anything you like right so i'm
going to call this the X okay just
because I know that was the first thing
that came to my mind okay so if that
little square there is x by x okay that
makes this distance it's the short side
okay and this one here okay so you can
see why i went for it it seems a little
better in that so i'm going to get rid
of this because that's a totally
different x yeah my volume here will be
x 20 minus two x 25 you sorry fit my
numbers room okay so far so good now do
you remember where do I go from here I
got my quantity in terms of one variable
and they're always my next step I wanted
to differentiate right now I couldn't
differentiate that it's a product so I
could use my ruler why bother right he
was probably better just to expand it
out okay so i actually just to save you
a bit of time I think I already got my
numbers for this necessary to write for
me for the sides yes now before I
differentiate and get into finding
stationary points
when I kind of feel right domain you
someone to notice because people always
forget it and then they go and do
working without noticing the domain
actually has implications for which
answers work on which ones don't so what
is Adam hmm so x is less than 20 / that
was helpful okay so X here right I've
got a restriction PR right which is that
X kind of go further than halfway so
excess me less than 15 why this smaller
side is going to it's going to reach its
limit first right so X has got to be
lesson 10 now could it could it be equal
to 10 then you just have one rectangle
yeah that's right you get the middle
like this thing greatest books of all
time for now what it's worth where I saw
this question they actually did say yeah
you can totally have it as 10 and then
you get a box with volume 0 right I
think that's a lot of the body when they
uh oh I'm figuring the question implies
you must have a box for the time you're
finished okay so there's one side of the
restriction there's another side right
what's the other side it's bigger than
less than 0 I have to make bigger than
less than 0 I have to make some cut of
some kind right because if I don't it's
Tucker's erecting when I can't I can
make like a taco out of it but I
wouldn't make it balls today's my
restrictions will come back to this in a
minute